where did boba fett get his fly armor he
was originally supposed to be anakin's
brother eaten by a sarlacc twice see how
the baddest bounty hunter in the galaxy
became the boba fetts that we know and
love
it may be hard for fed fanatics to
fathom but george lucas had no idea that
boba fetts would become a fan favorite
on the return of the jedi commentary
track he said in the case of boba fett's
death had i known he was going to turn
into such a popular character i probably
would have made it a little bit more
exciting he became such a favorite of
everybody's that for having such a small
part he had a very large presence and
now that his history has been told in
the first trilogy it makes it even more
of a misstep that we wouldn't make more
out of the event of his defeat it's an
interesting admission from lucas because
it answers the age-old question of why
such a cool character experience such an
ignominious end the short answer to
lucas fett's death deserves as little
attention as any of the other thugs and
aliens that luke and his friends
dispatched return of the jedi editor
dwayne dunham who was the first person
to wear the boba fett armor in a 1978
screen test said in 2014 that he and
others tried to talk lucas out of
killing fett in such a dumb way we kind
of mounted a protest saying you can't do
that to boba fett he's deserving of more
but they threw him in lucas also
admitted on the return of the jedi
commentary track that he almost added a
new scene at drawing the special edition
revamps in the 1990s which would have
seen phet emerging alive from the
sarlacc pit i'd contemplated putting in
that extra shot where he climbs out of
the hull but you know i figure that's it
doesn't quite fit in the end
ultimately fans are probably thankful
after all fed's re-emergence in
mandalorian wouldn't have been nearly as
effective if fans had already seen him
climb out of the sarlacc's mouth in the
late 90s you were dead
she was left for dead on the sands of
tatwin
as was i
but fate sometimes steps in to rescue
the wretched
of course by the time the return of the
jedi special edition came out in 1997
fans had already seen boba fett emerge
from the sarlacc pit alive the only
problem is that he immediately fell back
in it a story happened in the officially
licensed star wars comic book series
from marvel comics in star wars issue 81
which is the first story to take place
after the end of return of the jedi fett
escapes by being violently burped up
injured and dazed some nearby jawas pick
him up and put him inside their massive
sandcrawler inside is also r2d2 whom han
solo leia and luke eventually rescue
from the speeding crawler at one point
han finds fett and tries to help him but
fett attacks and is left behind as a
sand crawler speeds right into the
sarlacc pit so why did this happen
according to some sources writer joe
duffy desperately wanted to use boba
fett but the only way luca's film would
allow it was if she put him back into
the pit when she was done with him
bummer
it's somewhat ironic that george lucas
decided not to add in new scenes of boba
fett escaping the sarlacc [ __ ] because
he thought it would be out of place as
many fans feel the scenes he did add
with boba fett are among the most
contrived additions to the entire
revamped trilogy and that's saying a lot
because while some of the changes in the
special edition were simple effects
tweaks done to enhance a film with new
technology or restoring lost footage
others changed important character
moments most famously by having greedo
shoot first instead of han during their
confrontation at the maas eisley cantina
the first newfound footage was added to
a new hope during the cantina sequence
where han runs into jabba the hurt
shortly after shooting greedo the scene
was filmed way back in the 70s for the
original film birds have been cut
because the effects for jabba weren't
good enough when it was restored in the
90s with cgi though in addition to jabba
they also added in boba fett just as a
sort of easter egg for fans it's his
appearance in return of the jedi though
that some feat fanatics despise lucas
added a short bit with fete leering at
jabba's dancers and playfully touching a
dancer on the chin as he walks out
what's wrong with this you ask a large
part of what made boba fett scary was
that he seemed to have no human
weaknesses or vices just a relentless
dedication to his goal these special
edition tweaks however present him just
like any other guy distracted by the
beautiful women around him while this
does open the door for fan theories
about his getting knocked into the
sarlacc because he was distracted by
leia's gold bikini it also reveals that
years after lucas was first surprised by
the fan love for the character he still
didn't understand what made the aloof
bounty hunter so cool in the first place
you can tell by looking at fed that he's
pretty well armored and carries around a
lot of gear his go-to weapon is an ee3
carbine rifle also closed at hand are a
disrupter pistol and the concussion
grenade launcher then there's a
flamethrower dart launcher fiber cord
wrist launcher gauntlet vibroblades
concussive rocket and a jetpack fett's
helmet also allows for full 360-degree
vision it interfaces with his ship's
computer provides water can seal against
changes in atmospheric pressure record
video and amplify sound the armor itself
is designed to resist the elements and
minimize impact from anything including
blast to fire while the gauntlets are
decked out with a host of different
types of rockets most of which are meant
to stun rather than kill since a bounty
hunter can't get paid if he blows up his
prey of course most of this never made
it into the film and realistically fett
did almost nothing in the original
trilogy beyond looking cool and then
selling han solo down the river to jabba
but it was the love of the character's
potential that inspired later star wars
writers to flesh him out in other
projects besides his iconic armor boba
fett also flies a very specific ship
which boasts a different design from
other ships in the star wars universe
and it also used to boast a very
specific name as well slave 1. though
the ship is never called slave one by
name in any of the live-action films the
designation was used in extended
universe projects like toys video games
comics and cartoons for decades however
in 2021 the new lego star wars
mandalorian sets came out and the ship
was just called boba fett's starship in
an interview with jedi news the lego
star wars designers said that the name
slave one quote it's just something that
disney doesn't want to use anymore of
course some fans were internet outraged
but by any name it's still a cool ship
boba fett's starship as a republic era
fire spray 31 class spacecraft
previously owned by fett's father jango
fett during the clone wars like fed's
portable armory of tools and weapons on
his person the starship is highly
customized and armed to the teeth with
both subtle and striking weaponry one of
the most unique features of the starship
is its ability to rotate on a gimbal
flying vertically in the air in space
while landing horizontally all while
keeping the pilot seat and cargo area
facing upright
there are many different languages in
star wars and a special code shared
between boba fett and his father jango
fett is one of them first identified as
a specific language in a 2019 video on
the star wars kids youtube channel
titled every language and star wars that
code is briefly heard in episode 2
attack of the clones when obi-wan kenobi
meets the two at their home on kamino
django speaks to his son infect code as
obi-wan questions a bounty hunter about
any recent trips to coruscant and his
feelings about the clone army created in
his image it's not clear exactly what
django tells a sudden feat code but it's
clear it was instruction to close a
nearby closet containing django's
mandalorian armor
the code is never heard or spoken of
again implying that effect code was
probably created by django to privately
converse with his son
boba fett isn't a born and raised
mandalorian but that hasn't stopped him
from being the armored fighter everyone
thinks of when they think of
mandalorians fett is an exact clone of
his father django who was a foundling of
the mandalorians foundlings were a key
part of mandalorian culture in which the
planet's warriors adopted orphaned
children and raised them as mandalorians
dinjarin in the mandalorian is similarly
a foundling django's traditional
mandalorian armor is passed down to phet
following the former bounty hunter's
death at the hands of jedi mace window
the original armor was all over silver
bescar metal with the helmet featuring
blue stripes along the viewpoints fett
later customized his father's armor with
new green and red paint and added even
more tools and weapons to his belt in
the mandalorian fett is open about not
being mandalorian but still wearing the
armor because it was given to him by his
father your father was a foundling
yes
even fought in the mandalorian civil
wars
then that armor belongs to you this
strange anecdote actually came from luke
skywalker himself mark hamill in twitter
exchanges in 2018 hamill shared that he
once pitched to star wars creator george
lucas to have the fete character be
luke's real mother underneath the helmet
i have always been more than willing to
generously share my many many terrible
ideas and the off chance we might
stumble across one that could actually
be useful hamel also said the suggestion
was quote the only way we could top
vader being my father and that he
pictured the character as a double agent
working clandestinely for the rebels
boba fett may not have been revealed as
luke skywalker's mother but the bounty
hunter was almost written as anakin
skywalker's stepbrother in the book
skywalking the life and films of george
lucas it is revealed that lucas
considered making fit and anakin related
though the biography came out in 1983
lucas was reportedly already considering
ideas for prequel films to his original
trilogy according to lucas's ex-wife
marcia quote george had boba fett and
vader being brothers and the prequels
but the idea was ultimately deemed silly
and scrapped anakin skywalker did have a
stepbrother however in owen lars owen
was the stepson of shmee skywalker
anakin's mother owen and his wife beru
took a baby luke skywalker in after the
death of padme amidala and anakin's
transition to the dark side
before disney bought luca's film and
subsequently scrapped several star wars
projects boba fett was planned as a main
character of the dark action game star
wars 1313 and was also the intended
subject of a solo esque standalone film
the video game was set among the darker
sides of the galaxy on coruscant's level
1313 with players first assuming the
role of an unnamed bounty hunter and
them playing as fetch when the game was
introduced to e3 in 2012 creators said
players would use exotic weapons to help
fett investigate a criminal conspiracy
in the darkest lowest levels of the
planet-wide metropolis a more recent fep
focused offering was a reported
standalone film similar to solo though
the project was never formally announced
rumors swelled in 2013 and again in 2018
that disney and lucasfilm had been
working on a boba fett movie with
director james mangold but later that
year entertainment outlets confirmed the
fed movie was no more around the same
time disney and lucasfilm began heavily
promoting the space western series the
mandalorian on disney plus so it can
likely be assumed that plot points
characters in that fat film either
overlapped with the mandalorian
mythology or were perceived to
potentially contradict it at the end of
the day effects resurrection would come
solely via the mandalorian and will
continue with the book of boba fett
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]